a truly remarkable life story linked to
the city where President Biden is
holding the G7 meetings with other world
leaders today Hiroshima Japan that is
where the U.S dropped the first atomic
bomb 8 15 a.m in the morning in August
of 1945.
the civilian death toll was truly
catastrophic the Carnage extreme but the
U.S had calculated this was what was
necessary to end World War II Zhang sat
down with a woman who lived in Hiroshima
when the bomb was dropped nearly 80
years ago she is one of the few
residents still alive to share this
story
for taeko shatama Hungry everyone
cooking is about much more than food but
more nice
it is a way to preserve history great
grandma has food and this dish thank you
for having all of this wonderful food
thank you for making it is at the heart
of her Story of Survival would you like
some more Sukiyaki Japanese Hot Pot was
the first real meal her family ate
together after World War II ended nearly
80 years ago and that night we went and
bought
beef and all kinds of stuff to make
Sukiyaki
and we ate so much we got sick
it was a meal that almost never happened
[Music]
chitama was 22 years old living in
Hiroshima Japan in August 1945 when the
U.S dropped an atomic bomb over the city
but shatama was not there the day before
she had taken a train to a friend's
house a few Towns over to pick up a bag
of rice when she returned to the
Hiroshima train station the next day she
faced a land ravaged by war no streetcar
was running and it was flat completely
flat so I was able to walk from the East
End train station eight Rivers
it Bridges to home with this big bag of
rice that she gave me you took the bag
of rice all the way home of course
it rice with rationed
shatama did not see a living Soul on the
several mile Trek to her family's home
when she arrived four miles from the
epicenter of the bomb the house was
still standing but the neighborhood was
devastated every piece of glass was
broken the blast killed an estimated 140
000 people including shatama's youngest
sister Nobu she was on a streetcar in
the city when the bomb hit were you
angry at the United States I was angry
about the war but I thought it was
awfully cruel to use atomic bomb on
people
shatama was born in Seattle after her
parents immigrated there from Japan at
the age of eight shitama moved to Japan
with her siblings for school then when
World War II ended chitama and her
surviving siblings were on the first
ship back to the U.S to reunite with
their parents oh and then we first saw
them we all cried cried and cried and
cried we were so happy to see them
shatama does not Harbor resentment
toward America for the bomb and she's
proud of the friendship between the U.S
and Japan these are beautiful at the
national Bonsai museum in Washington DC
and nearly 400 year old bonsai tree was
also in Hiroshima when the bomb dropped
this tree survived the atomic bombing
atomic bomb yeah and so did you yeah and
not many people can say that
if trees could talk
shitama got married to a fellow Japanese
American and went on to raise three
children in Maryland now they have 12
grandchildren and 13 great-grandchildren
that's my story
all of whom have heard her remarkable
Tales over decades who is that that's me
and some just starting to learn them
stories not only about survival but
about family and forgiveness
[Music]
and all those great grandbabies all
those grandchildren will be together to
celebrate Thai that's what our friends
and family call her at the end of the
month when she turns 100 years old and
get this her two sisters who also
survived the atomic bomb they will be
turning 96 and 98 years old so you know
I had to ask the secret and I love to
hear it guys it wasn't diet and exercise
Ty says if you want to live a long life
eat a lot of rice which for me was very
validating growing up eating three meals
with rice a day Tony oh wow I had rice
for dinner last night
it's a very uh it's a very powerful
piece I love the sparkle in her eye all
these years later and and so wise what
she had to say there she's she doesn't
Harbor resentment toward the U.S what
she what she resented was the war what
she hated was the War what was it like
for you sitting across from her all
these years later hearing that kind of
wisdom
Tony that's exactly what struck me is
that someone who survived something so
devastating who lost a loved one after
this who really could have been
traumatized and let this guide her
entire life instead she says she chose
to live every life every moment of her
life that she was giving to the fullest
she chose Grace she shows forgiveness
she chose to focus on that huge
beautiful family of hers and not to be
angry and certainly not to hold any
resentment because she says she's such a
proud American who came back here to
visit her to be with her parents once
again and to live out the rest of her
life so even though it was so
devastating she says that she was better
for it because it made her stronger I
think there's a second secret there to a
long life rice and you've got to forgive
and then live for the moment you're in
Ouija thank you very much it's a
beautiful story